with the world churning virtual cyber
attacks are constantly flooding new
headlines
kovit 19 accelerated the current digital
transformation
and the year 2020 witnessed several data
breaches
since technology has become more
intertwined with our daily lives
it is no surprise that the need for
skilled cyber security professionals is
increasing
on that note hey everyone welcome yet to
another exciting video by simply learn
which will take you through the top
cyber security career options available
today but before we begin if you're new
here and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and that bell icon for interesting tech
videos
every day there is a significant lack of
skilled cyber security professionals who
can tackle the cybersecurity challenges
faced
daily hence a career in cyber security
is demanding and equally rewarding
finding the right career path in the
cyber security industry isn't always
easy here we are here to help you with
that
there are a few prerequisites for a
career in cyber security
the basic one being a bachelor's degree
in a subject relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and kick
start your cyber security journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career
you can check out our video on the top 5
cyber security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to executive management and
everything in between
there are several cyber security paths
available today
it is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience
here let us have a look at the top five
cyber security job roles today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer
network engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting network
equipment
they also configure and maintain
firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker the annual average salary
of a network engineer in the us is
eighty-five thousand and ninety-eight
dollars and in india it is around five
hundred ten thousand rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst
as an information security analyst your
primary duty is to protect sensitive
information
information security analysts create and
implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks
they monitor data access and ensure
compliance with policies
depending on the cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further
in the us an information security
analyst earns 89
and 140 dollars annually and in india
they earn 6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees
third on our list is ethical hacker they
are also known as penetration testers
they are network security consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like
how a hacker would do they probe and
test the network using various
penetration tools and
software they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results
in the us a certified ethical hacker
earns around 93 000
on an annual average basis and in india
they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations
they design robust security structures
that are capable of preventing malware
attacks
a security architect approves the
installation of routers
vpn and firewalls their duties go beyond
just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides
security architects in the us make a
handsome sum of 124 000
a year on an average and in india they
make nearly 21 lakh
80 000 rupees and finally fifth on our
list
is chief information security officer
ciso
they are senior level officers in an
organization
they ensure the safety of the
information they develop implement and
maintain
information security and risk management
programs
they also interact with stakeholders and
regularly brief them with information
security concerns
the average annual salary of a chief
information security officer in the
states
is a whopping 165 000
annually and in india it is 22 lakh 22
and 845 rupees several companies are
looking for skilled
cyber security professionals phillips
siemens
google microsoft and ge to name a few
with passion the right amount of
experience and relevant certifications
you can grow your cyber security career
you can check out simply learn cyber
security expert
master's program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure
secure your data run risk analysis
achieve
compliance and much more so with that we
come to the end of this video on the
cyber security career
think we missed anything important do
let us know in the comments section
below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here